[Music]
Disney's animated movies are so good
that they just never get old when a good
movie is used to copy in another movie
viewers notice right away we didn't tell
number one to check out a really
terrible copy of The Lion King if this
is your first time visiting this channel
don't forget to subscribe to the things
and please give this video a big thumbs
up here are 10 animated movies that
copied Disney frozen land and frozen
Disney's frozen was not only a hit at
the box office in the United States but
an international sensation even let it
go rang through speakers in everyone's
households the animated movie was an
original concept that became an instant
classic accompanied by a paraphernalia
accessories and Halloween costumes it's
one thing to admire the popularity of
another movie and it's hard to resist
jumping on the bandwagon and
capitalizing on Disney success this is
exactly what happened when the French
Canadian film The Legend of cirilla was
rebranded and even renamed to frozen
land in hopes of reaching similar levels
of success as frozen frozen lands
distributing company phase 4 quickly
found itself entangled in a lawsuit with
Disney which is never a good call
Disney won the lawsuit demanding
financial compensation that required the
frozen logo not to be used and that all
DVDs with the frozen land branding be
destroyed sadly this entire ordeal could
have been avoided as frozen land
storyline is actually completely
original and nothing like the plot of
frozen had phase 4 not planned on
manipulating parents into buying the
wrong DVD they would have saved
themselves all the legal trouble and
ironically they would have made a lot
more money Autobots and cars it's no
surprise that a critically acclaimed
film like cars would stir creativity
around the world including in one of the
most competitive countries like China
however inspiration was taken a little
too far with their movie the Autobots
it's in Disney's interest to protect
their original content as they are
pushing their way into the world's
second largest economy with Disney
opening up a theme park in Shanghai and
investing millions of dollars they were
not willing to let the issues slide the
poster for Cars 2 and the Autobots are
remarkably similar so much so that some
parents took their kids to see the
Autobots expecting it to be Disney and
Pixar Anna
that was equally successful in China as
it is in the United States however the
Chinese film directors and producers
deny any similarity between the movies
claiming that the idea is completely
original
nevertheless they reassure audiences
that the movie sequel will be of
superior quality and will be distinctly
different from its American counterpart
though the characters look very similar
on the poster their names are different
and the production value is visibly much
lower than cars or cars too it will be
interesting to see how a scandal like
this could turn into some major
competition for Disney animated movies
The Land Before Time and Bambi for many
of us we know that watching Bambi comes
at a very sad cost of having to watch
Bambi's mom being shot by a hunter the
scene is famous for its shockingly
honest portrayal of the lost young
animals must contend with let us not
forget how this message is repeated in
several other Disney animated movies
including the death of Mufasa in the
Lion King though these scenes are tragic
they serve as important lessons about
the cycle of life and the importance of
allowing the space to grieve the loss of
a loved one especially someone as
important as a parent plan before time
the story of a long next dinosaur copies
the exact storyline early on in the
movie Littlefoot the young protagonist
long-necked dinosaur catches a glimpse
of a t-rex while innocently playing
little foots mother comes to his aid and
ends up sacrificing herself for the
safety of her only child who mustn't
survive on his own to find the rest of
his kind including his grandparents the
scene is absolutely devastating and
instantly brings to mind through the
loss we all felt while watching Bambi
though the scene is similar the
storylines differ and in the ends of
both films serve as wonderful viewing
experiences that are nostalgic Lee
remembered Rugrats in Paris and lady in
the [ __ ] we're willing to bet that
aside from one famous scene most of us
have forgotten a lot of the plot points
in the Disney classic Lady and the [ __ ]
the scene is so famous that has become a
trope for couples both on and off screen
we're talking about a romantic date
involving a shared plate of spaghetti
and that one long strand of pasta that
leads to a bashful kiss however there is
a difference between recreating a movie
moment with your sweetheart and copying
one of Disney's
oldest films Rugrats in Paris crosses
the line and does just that copying the
most famous scene of lady in the [ __ ]
in Rugrats in Paris spike in his poodle
girlfriends share a pizza their meals
unlike Lady and the [ __ ] is neither
fresh nor appetizing as it consists of a
sticky pizza seasoned with swarming
flies it doesn't seem to come out of an
oven either which is confusing scene as
how the two dogs get stucked the stringy
cheese they end up stuck together the
steam isn't just disappointing because
it's unoriginal but it's also illogical
causing us to question the decision to
copy it in the first place
have you seen this scene in other movies
Izzy's way home and finding dory the
asylum is a production company best
known for its mock Buster's that thrive
on copying and ridiculing pre-existing
movies asylum is most famous for its
sharknado series and has decided to
branch out with an animation division
Disney and Pixar success makes it an
easy target for the production company
that released its first animated feature
film Izzy's way home the movie is a
complete ripoff of finding dory even
though it was technically released first
knowing how popular Finding Nemo was the
company took advantage of the hype
surrounding the sequel and decided to
create the same story about a fish
trying to find her way through the ocean
to her long-lost mother in this case
however Izzy's malformation or defining
characteristic isn't short-term memory
loss or a small fin instead Izzy
struggles to fit in because of a
birthmark the strange and almost
grotesque animation definitely enhances
this feature for the audience Asylum
even when as far as finally not one but
two famous voices for their characters
though not the hilarious distinctive
voice of Ellen DeGeneres Joey Fatone and
Tori Spelling are two big names
providing the voices for Izzy's way home
his teams as Asylum has mastered the art
of imitation and plans to keep it up for
as long as it remains successful the
secret life of pets and Toy Story Disney
Pixar's first full-length feature was
Toy Story and it made history voice
actors Tim Allen and Tom Hanks brought
Buzz Lightyear and woody respectively to
life the idea of inanimate objects we
love coming to life and our absence was
original and wildly successful fitzy
that the secret life of pets took more
than just one page from the Toy Story
playbook in fact both movies even have
characters playing practically identical
roles while woody rules the ruse of toys
once Andy his owner leaves max a dog in
the secret life of pets does the same
when his owner katie is away however one
day max is upset when katie brings home
a rescue dog named Duke this inspires
max to enact a plan to get rid of Duke
who he worries might overshadow him the
scheme is an exact replica of Woody's
plan to get rid of Andy's new favorite
toy Buzz Lightyear taking every
opportunity he has to turn him down and
get rid of him unfortunately for both
max and woody they end up getting in
just as much trouble while it's tempting
to restore their lives as it once was
before they felt threatened by the
arrival of something new the secret of
Mulan and Mulan Mulan is a Disney movie
that was produced with the attention to
detail that Disney is known for even the
glowing Chinese calligraphy is actually
the names of artists that worked on the
production has died from Moo shus
comedic relief the movie's subject
matter is touching and inspiring
Mulan's disguised as an L warrior
continues to be the story audiences love
to watch and carry in their hearts and
memory for all the critical acclaim the
movie has received it's even more
surprising that it's the subject of a
terrible copy called the secret of Mulan
the movie released the same year as a
bug's life seem to have used the success
of both movies as inspiration for a very
strange take of Mulan Mulan is a
cockroach who undergoes a journey that
entails fighting and defeating an evil
hun cockroach most disappointingly is
that instead of trying to save her
family's honour this copied caterpillar
Mulan is focused on winning over the
love and affection of the butterfly
prince it seems to us that the secret of
Mulan should remain a secret as it pales
in comparison to the epic story of Mulan
who proves her strength despite the
limitations imposed on her gender
Aladdin and Aladdin with 1d it's either
impressive or foolish to attempt to
recreate another version of a Disney
classic like Aladdin a German company
known as dingo Pictures has made several
low-budget and low quality versions of
Disney's favorite animated movies their
take on Aladdin is unimaginative Lee
called Aladdin
with 1d the
that one letter is the only difference
in the title is not the sole reason this
adaptation is such a flop Aladdin is no
exception for the excessively low
standards this company holds for its
copy productions for each film dingo
Pictures uses poor animation and employs
no more than two voice actors for all
the characters as the actors are German
the company also created a poorly
translated version for international
release the dialogue is poorly acted and
poorly recorded sometimes even badly
synced to the characters however the
iconic characters appear recognizable
and they include a blue Genie dingo
Productions has somehow managed to find
its way into American markets through
its dollar store Vince ales Hunchback of
Notre Dom the secret of the Hunchback
Disney's The Hunchback of Notre Dom is
no stranger to being terribly remade The
Hunchback of Notre Dom can be found as a
dingo productions version that is so far
from doing the movie justice it might as
well have a different name the secret of
the Hunchback however depicts a strange
take on the movie though it has much
less depth to its message it comes
across as an almost comedic version of
the Disney film the twist with the
secret of the Hunchback as opposed to
the Hunchback of Notre Dom is that the
end of the movie reveals that
Quasimodo's hunchback was actually just
a way of concealing his wings and the
secret of the Hunchback the audience
finds out that the secret is that
Quasimodo was an angel disguised as a
hunchback this was meant to drive home
the movies message that inner beauty
means more than outer beauty have you
ever seen a remake of a movie that was
unintentionally hilarious make sure you
give us your so bad it's funny movie
recommendations in the comments
Leo the lion and the Lion King Disney's
pulling its contents from Netflix was
exactly the licensed Netflix needed to
produce some low-quality Disney ripoffs
it's hard for us to blame Netflix for
this movie as it tries to stay ahead of
Disney's plan for their own streaming
service their problem with Netflix is
that it is a convenient alternative that
often outweighs spending more money on
higher quality products this is
definitely the case for Leah the lion a
low-budget terrible remake of Disney's
The Lion King the movies premise is
confused by the fact that subtitles do
not match the dialogue or storyline the
subtitles are so badly edited that they
even use the wrong names
the characters and dimension things that
are never even referenced in the movie
to add insult to injury the graphics are
very hard to watch the background is
almost always blurry and the characters
aren't always clear so that they often
appear as if they're part of a video
game that never fully loaded it seems
that Netflix took advantage of the
movies target audience
assuming that children would be less
concerned about the visual quality of
the movies they watch meanwhile parents
or viewers who happen upon Leo the Lion
by mistake definitely regret the
decision within moments of the movie
starting do you know of any animated
movies that copy Disney's that didn't
make our list let us know in the
comments and that's all for ten animated
movies that copied Disney make sure to
like this video and subscribe to the
things
- catch more videos like this thanks for
watching
[Music]